hey this is exciting
we have
possibly possibly a new top voicemail
caller
you can call my voicemail anytime
2192davidp
is the number
this guy is straight out of central
casting you you've got to listen to this
just no introduction just take a listen
gary from new york right
i mean i i listen to you
a lot of times i do listen to you in
this cable thing anyway
i'm just calling you that
you talk a lot of garbage i don't know
you you sound like the president talk a
lot of
nonsense things that it's all lies
something with you the thing i
understand how could you not i i'm
pretty sure this is real guys
we uh we we looked up who this actually
is
this is really
a guy from where he sounds like he's
from it's it appears to be completely
real talk about this guy he's the worst
president
and the worst vice president we got in
this country question ronald reagan let
me excuse me my language uh
what's that guy's name jimmy carlo
that may have been uh freudian slip
there
maybe he really does think reagan was
terrible but he doesn't want to admit it
excuse me
why you don't talk about this guy that
he's a bad president he's killing his
country guesses up
that people coming over this country
and these things are always funny
because you know when you really break
down this guy's a character it's funny
but when you break this stuff down
um the gas prices they have nothing to
do with joe biden
when they were low under obama i wasn't
praising obama
um when they were high under trump and
then low under trump i wasn't blaming
trump because the president has barely
anything to do with gas prices um the
border situation has barely changed
since donald trump left and joe biden
took over you know it it's it's funny
but this this is weaponized
disinformation into this guy now who
believes all these things that aren't
true
this is a forget he's ruining this
country so bad
that he don't even say nothing about it
talk about trump all the time trump
trump trump he must be in love with this
guy
talk about the president the vice
president clown and the joker
they know they don't belong to sitting
there they belong in in the clown in in
a circle now of course
not only have i been so critical of joe
biden in some areas that many of my own
viewers say david
you got to be you got to be easier on
biden
um but i praise the guy when he does
things right like almost single-handedly
ending the drone war as we talked about
at the top of the show today
this guy is a real clown right he's
worse than jimmy carter
we passed a guy
this guy and you don't talk bad about
this guy at all yeah we do
nothing nothing oh but you put this in
the air one of these days now junkie son
you know junkie's not a term i use but
again
hunter biden has nothing to do with the
biden administration what do people want
me to say
you know if i'm listening to it if i if
i i don't know if i'm watching
you know because you know
every time i listen to you i'm telling
you
nothing like
that i don't know you should like a guy
that doesn't know what doll he's talking
about then don't
don't watch you know i mean people get
upset that there's so many shows out
there that i think are trash
i don't watch a single one of them when
you got a stupid president a stupid like
a joke
vice president for me is a joker
i don't know and then they got the other
guy
the the the love boy there
i don't know where to get these people
from and you know whatever say nothing
bad about these people who's the love
boy by the way anybody know what that's
about you must love them
they are the worst president the worst
price president in this country
and i can't stand every time i see these
two clowns i feel like to break the tv
right in their faces oh
you know i don't wish nothing to the guy
but everybody's not every day with this
corona videos and he's got blood in his
head all these marines he killed
for no reason
he could have got these guys out
no problem
nothing
instead
he preferred to kill the protecting kids
for no reason
and it
it's gotten very very boring but uh that
is a fascinating caller that is straight
out of central casting of course not
making a single good political point
but uh certainly saying it in a very
very funny way we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the death of bob dole uh a giant of the
senate 1996 republican presidential
nominee
um against bill clinton in the uh
eventual re-election of bill clinton an
interesting guy has passed away we will
talk about bob dole
um debt collectors can now text email
and direct message you on social media
debt collector
a very interesting
uh
profession
and i
cringe a little bit at calling it that a
lot of scams in the world of debt
collecting we are going to talk about it
on today's bonus show and also
in addition to learning that stacy
abrams is going to be running
again for governor in georgia as a
democrat of course
we are now learning that david perdue
the former georgia senator republican
who lost
to john ossoff
is going to be challenging incumbent
republican governor republican governor
brian kemp
that's also very interesting kemp
presumably would be the less trumpy of
the two candidates we're going to talk
about how that race is going to break
down on today's bonus show do not miss
today's bonus show get instant access by
signing up at joinpacman.com you can use
the coupon code better21
to save a bundle
and
also remember that our members at
jointpakman.com
get priority access to me
during the upcoming viewer town hall
december 14th 6 pm eastern on the pacman
live youtube channel that's it for
today's show see you on today's bonus
show back with another show tomorrow